quick tour update gang the state trashy
tour is a cook and we're adding shows
and we're coming to a city near you
bring the squad out and come see us yeah
baby plus we got new digs next week
we're going to be in Oklahoma City
Dallas Texas Houston Texas Austin Texas
Texas second show added there then in
April we're hitting New Haven
Connecticut Burlington Vermont new
second shows added in both those cities
what then we're going to Tampa Florida
second show added there you go Dania
Beach Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Cleveland get your tickies
now you snooze you lose see you out
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find that at the group
to be classy or to just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave trolley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here with Toody's in a new
edition baby I know oh the rich get
richer she is spending that a couple of
Papa John's gonna be opening up in the
neighborhood soon my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage she is an
international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan hey what's up
gang thanks for tuning in as always make
sure you rate if you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
cooking and obviously I don't have to
say it in the presence of these guys the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com check it the [__] out
gang it's a party over there fellow
shareholders in the building and gang
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes it's all look good works the ones
the twos the threes the fours he crosses
the t's dots the eyes and let's not
forget he's got that big old wee-wee now
you can get a peek at him ladies give it
up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody hey what's up dude look at him
back there beautiful day out here I love
this dude we got in here so you're
making me giggle for years
ain't [__] lying gang we couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly and
I mean incredibly special guests here
with us today for the first time of
course he is the host of the Adam
Freeland show give it up for Adam
Freeland everybody there he is the world
famous
wow you guys are real pros you guys are
like [__] radio
[__] for seven years I mean you guys
have catchphrases we go real morning
that was Unreal I feel like I'm out of
class right now I feel like the new boys
are like it's like uh when the like the
kids in the wire they like come in and
like take over the corners you're like
Marlo's crew it's like when Frank Lucas
gets out of jail in the 90s what the
[__] happened in New York what's going
on with these new these new kids why do
these [__] shaving their [__]
it's gay to eat [__]
I don't trust her yeah buddy thanks for
sitting down with us yeah thanks for
having me guys I know you're a busy
Mania congratulations on this on this
new setup thank you brother appreciate
it I can't stop looking at this picture
of you yeah he's gonna take a running I
don't like it I don't like it wipe me up
looking right at me right now
the eyes follow you wherever you go
looking for lunch meat or something
Jesus Christ I feel like that picture's
gonna pass me I feel like you're gonna
give me a swirly make out with your
girlfriend
finger pop my girlfriend
this is what you get for being a nerd
it's all [__] what's up friedling Dork
what's my sister doing she's all right
you [__] her yeah damn just being to
be good to her give us the back story
dude what's the scoop where are you from
I'm from Vegas oh that's crazy yeah not
a lot of people knocked off the Jump
local like it was born and raised about
no I was born in L.A really uh Santa
Monica yeah see and I'm on the Wikipedia
page for the hospital I was born at no
[__] yeah so the only time my dad came
even close to saying he's proud of me
you saw my someone told me I told him my
name was on the Wikipedia he's like I
can't believe as like notable births
yeah notable birth number two who else
is on there Santa Monica's got to be a
couple of people Neil Patrick Harris
probably somebody I don't know St John's
Hospital hold on so you're born in Santa
Monica I'm born in Santa Monica my
parents my parents were my dad was on a
list
they wanted to send my dad to Angola to
the Civil War right after my parents got
married so they had to come to America
so we got out what a getting was good
what the getting was good so I didn't
have to go to the bloodbath in Angola
parents are South Africa my parents are
South we're South African Jews and as
they were often told they were like as
if it wasn't for the Blicks it would be
you
[Laughter]
I don't know yeah no my yeah my my
family was there for like two
generations one and a half Generations
really and what does your mom and dad do
my mom is a dead woman and my dad is how
long has she been doing that uh three
years your mom passed away three years
ago
yeah she passed away three years ago she
was like uh she my dad's an architect
okay yeah so your dad's an architect and
then then my family lost all their money
when I was four and it never
that's why we went to Vegas yeah what
was it did I make it all back bad deal
what happened they thought because it
was like the fastest growing city in
America and then it was just it's kind
of they kind of hated it so what
happened give us a scoop uh the Savings
and Loan crisis in 1991 Southern
California my dad was an architect so he
was designing houses in the San Fernando
Valley okay and then he hates the
Republicans because he blames the
Republicans for it he thinks it's
Reagan's fault I would never say that I
would never say that about a great man
[Laughter]
I was born in 1987 and I I do take pride
in the fact that I was born at the end
of the rig
yeah man I slept good at night as a
little kid I was like thank God
know that you got another guy on the
other end of the phone if something's
gonna happen yeah
over there all right well I guess you're
gonna nuke them all I guess at the end
of course
this is trying to Reagan and the Andy
was just gone he's just fully gone
mentally yeah yeah and um who isn't
though what I'm sorry we had already
picked the Russians I mean I guess it's
whatever but
um I guess Nancy I just found this out
had a psychic who's making like State
decisions no [__] straight up yeah she
had a psychic who was like changing like
the times and dates of like State
functions and like uh based upon the
premonition or whatever based upon like
yeah I don't know the yikes really yeah
I like the cocktail from what I
understand she also like the oral sex as
well they said she was the super head of
Hollywood yeah [__] yeah huh shout out
to her how do you know that you've been
hanging out it comes out literally every
four years on Twitter where they're like
did you know Nancy Reagan was a was a
throat goat yeah and then
um you gotta get on Twitter every four
years there's a day on Twitter where
everyone's like I can't believe it but
it's just like I don't know it's been
it's like the thing it's like Cosby
being a rapist it was like every every
four years everyone would be like and
then finally Hannibal said it and that
stuff yeah finally finally
finally the federal government
finally the government
federal investigation but yeah
apparently she schlobbed all of
Hollywood yeah Sinatra this and that and
the other day she used to go well
documented she said uh I think she used
to go into like Hollywood executive's
offices and uh give them
up we're not gonna have any of this
commie talk here okay she was a great
wolf that's what that's what Castro
wants you to think yeah this is all
propaganda yeah it's pretty cool that
she sucked her way up there uh to the
top you know hey I guess women have been
doing that I've been trying to do it for
[__] a decade
I'll be blaming Ronnie Riggs for your
dad making bad Investments let's go no
no no so um goddamn American here yeah
so that happened and then we moved to
Vegas was it a significant downgrade my
parents my parents were d-class so I I
kind of
they kind of still they kind of still
thought that they were rich rich yeah
and I was like we're not like we're not
which is the class which is like I kind
of I had some of that growing up but I
was like I was like why are you judging
people that are like living in the same
apartment complexes oh right so it made
me really shit's creek I have disdain
for well for wealth yeah especially like
you know I remember the night before I
moved to New York my I called my dad and
I was like I'm gonna be a comedy stalker
he was like you're gonna fail and I was
like why and he's like we don't have
connections in Show Business and then I
realized that he was absolutely right
you don't happen to know Ernie Hudson
there are a ton of there are a ton of
people I was like you have to just be
the best I was like it's like uh it's a
meritocracy and then there I got here
and there were a ton of people who yeah
who stick yeah
no no no no you guys built this from you
built this temple from the ground up
hold on back this up my dad owns GE
your dad is uh is
wrong exactly yeah
Jack Welsh good friend of mine
um
hold on any brothers and sisters younger
sister yeah how old or how many more
years younger to the day so you guys
grew up together same birthday grew up
together all right and then so you're
living in Santa Monica until when how
old are you when you move we moved we
moved back to South Africa for a year it
did after Mandela got out and then
because my parents ran out of money so
we had to go back there no kidding and
then because because of the apartheid
might they couldn't get like all their
money out because they just had to leave
so they had they still had a little bit
of money there so so we lived there for
a year and a half I learned how to swim
there so you're proud your parents are
over there that's a weird fact
it was really it was uh also tried
pickles for the first time no no it was
like it was a traumatic experience my
parents took me to this woman I still
remember her name Laura or something and
she was just this woman wearing jeans
and wearing like fishing galoshes and
her philosophy on teaching a
four-year-old how to swim was um uh
survival yeah
I was like listen to her listen to her
it was a high school she knows how to
swim
where'd she do this in a pool or in the
ocean it was like an indoor pool I still
remember it was like one of my first
memories I wasn't crazy and like that
Panic that's it yeah because you
apparently you could do it when a kid is
like a baby a baby because yeah
yeah but if you're four you're like I'm
gonna die
I know it died fully clothed yeah I know
what dying is it's scary to die yeah
sure yeah wait hold on so you're living
in Santa Monica
the the the loan crisis hits I don't
yeah my parents my dad had like a he was
like building how like designing house
designing gotcha and then that went
South did you guys live in a nice house
I don't know Santa Monica no we had like
a like a townhouse like okay okay you
know it was nice and the thing with
South Africa he you got out of there
because they were gonna they were gonna
I mean I wasn't into the army yeah they
wanted to send my dad because my dad was
like a hippie in high school okay so
they found out he where he thought he
was a hippie but they found that he did
a humanitarian relief project in
Swaziland
or lesota one of the they're these two
tiny countries in the middle of South
Africa one of the two I forgot and then
he was on a list and then they were like
oh you've been selected for a
um reserves program so we could call you
up for any time in the next 30 Years
yikes to the military so he went to
college in London got out and studied
architecture and then came back and met
my mom and then they got married and
then they tried to send him to Angola
and he got the [__] out my dad you know
my dad's a real Jane Fonda you know it's
real
it's a real
dessert then we went after money left
the [__] the scores
when he was there or was it all cooled
down then no Mandela got out so it was
like the new country was starting okay
and then Mandela spoke at my grandma's
synagogue really yeah and she was like
tell you he was like tell your kids to
come back because my their whole
generation like Jewish South Africans
got the [__] out yeah they're like tell
them to come back we want we want to
build this new country with them too and
then uh so then yeah
yeah no no it was a white setup it was a
white lady
uh but my grandma still lives there she
lives in Cape Town yeah okay and so I
just went in January to see her and
she's she is also the throat the throat
of of South Africa Mandela she's my my
grandma Yeah the whole team the whole
Squad no no uh she's a good lady I don't
know why I said that in public
very nice woman she's divorced
okay yeah and what was Vegas like
uh apartment complex how many bedrooms
yeah
two bedrooms to be my sister share a
room and then we got when I was 14 we
got a house okay and like uh like
tracked housing like uh how close to the
strip so it's all like it's like you
have you seen the show Weeds yeah so
it's like all like um all the houses
look the same okay so it's all like a
cookie cutter yeah Suburban development
yeah yeah yeah it's like the Southwest
has a lot of places like that so like
Phoenix is like that sure I got you all
right yeah yeah and like Orange County
is like that too and like okay
um so yeah so we're like 30 minutes from
the store I mean it's 30 minutes from
anything and anywhere down yeah but
Vegas Vegas was like uh I don't know
yeah it was like uh I I don't know it
was like a weird place to grow up yeah
to go to public school private school
public school public school what was
your parents doing when you were there
was he still my dad as an architect no
my dad was uh he had like a company for
a bit and then you know he didn't he he
was like uh eventually he started a
magazine with my mom this was after I
whoa this was after I graduated high
school started a magazine College yeah
they started a Jewish magazine together
in Las Vegas yeah
Jewish Illustrated yeah yeah yeah the
the it's not like uh like local stuff or
like yeah it was like arts and culture
and I don't [__] know yeah and then
the 10 like just like um real nasty
Center folds
real spread eagle [__] yeah yeah just
like spreading this this situation you
know this thing just just uh you know
Gloria uh Miss July irva Fleischmann
yeah yikes just really just no no uh
editing just real Raw
and then where'd you go to college and
then I went to school in DC
um and I didn't visit before I went
there but they gave me a lot of money
because I I got good grades what was
what you're so you were a good student
in high school that was it I cheated a
lot I respect that I was a cheater yeah
yeah when my parents wanted an A's so
then I was like then I'll just try to do
the least amount of work to get the A's
I respect it so I learned how to well I
taught myself how to cheat in middle
school yeah because I was like it's just
a game did you have any any good any any
big
tactic that you used that you were
across your system there are a lot of
different systems yeah I found out that
well amazon.com was pretty new at the
time I found a lot of teachers were just
like copying like xeroxing uh the
quizzes from the teacher's guide so then
I would just buy those oh more that's
pretty cool
that's pretty [__] good I mean but I
was still like I'd still like take you
know the test at the end and be good but
I was just like it's not worth I didn't
know that you're supposed to like be
educated I got to learn yeah we're just
trying to get the score you're just
trying to get the score yeah it was very
Jewish
Vegas I got the point I got them I
thought you wanted the points
any sports in high school I played I
played baseball up until ninth grade and
then freshman ball is like when you
start going to the gym and my body
hadn't changed yet so
I just couldn't do the weight room and
stuff yeah okay my body was I I can't
cheat in the gym I was a bit of a late
bloomer I didn't have pubes I didn't
have a full Bush I'll say in ninth grade
we have a full budget there was a cute a
few stragglers but yeah okay what was
the high school mascot we I went to a
magnet high school
what does that mean yeah it's I don't
know you have to like take a test to get
in okay and smart kid
yeah but like cheating cheating yeah
okay yeah I just know it's like you know
if I want to be a lawyer
I want to go to law school that was like
my plan and I got into law school before
I started doing comedy nice but then I
went to school in DC what school in DC
GW ah she gotta be a good school I hated
it really yeah it's just like some of
the dumbest like
like new money tri-state area kids okay
yeah Ed Hardy was very popular in those
days sure and like everyone everyone's
like kids had their parents like
American Express black cards and stuff
that's crazy and I was like I just I
feel right I graduated in three years I
I got out early damn look at you I took
um
summer because I was like a nerd no no I
like college no you couldn't cheat well
it did not a little bit but like no I
just I I realized I wanted to learn and
you were in pre-law at the time I did uh
politics I did a international politics
really yeah it's [__] smart kid no
no dude
I don't know like a minus probably and
once you do that that's the points
what'd you do in the SATs I did all
right I think ours was out of 1600 so I
got 14. holy what is that good you guys
still remember they got an 880. you did
eight seven is that for your name that's
what you're good for your name yeah
that's what that kid back there that's
what you got dude look at that CTE look
at that CTE stair
Jesus Christ is Jovan Belcher over there
was that guy the Kansas the Kansas City
Chiefs that's the saddest story ever
well I don't know that the guy who like
killed his girlfriend then went to Andy
Reid's office and committed suicide Andy
Reid is like um Andy fat ass well you
guys are Philly boys that's what they
used to call them on he's like uh you
know Kelsey Grammer He Like Only Knows
tragedy in his life yes Andy Reid is the
same his like son he's Sons
guy that was like had like Advanced CT
like kills his girlfriend maybe their
infant child and then goes to Andy reads
off can you imagine a fat jolly old
Anthony where you just watch it come on
hey Lenny what's going on yeah what's
going on Boom he does like State Farm
commercials now yeah I mean he's just
like Kelsey he's like apparently Kelsey
Grammer everyone he's ever loved has
died yeah he went through a real tough
and he's just like he was apparently on
the set of Frasier and he was just a
like a drug like a stupor like like this
and then they say action be like nah
or somebody like that it was some famous
uh Hollywood writer that told that story
yeah yeah he would just snap into it'd
be all [__] up and then just snap into
it yeah yeah [__] professional uh
okay let's talk about Bluetooth uh knock
knock who's there my heart on let's go
listen
let's be honest uh-huh all right you
suddenly I'm [__] 400 pounds you
start getting older things don't work
the way they used to down there it's
just the way it is and if you need a
little boost yeah if you need a little
pep in the step in the Boudoir yeah do
yourself a favor get some blue chew they
should be calling these things high
school because I'm uh standing at ten
and two you know what they're hanging
laundry on this thing gang it's
fantastic that sounds weird to me saying
that but it is it's fantastic do
yourself a favor get over to Bluetooth
it's ed treatment delivered right to
your door you don't gotta go talk to
your pediatrician whoever you talk I
don't think pediatricians are allowed
guys it's the same active ingredients as
Viagra see Alice leviche at a fraction
of the cost yeah uh listen personal
endorsement this stuff works go check it
out I'll back that up
and so did she be prepared for a good
time anytime Bluetooth wants to help you
have better sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com chew it and do it
and they got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
using promo code garbage at checkout
just paying five dollars for the
shipping uh that's bluetooth.com promo
code garbage has received your first
month free visit bluetooth.com and for
more details and important safety
information and thank you Bluetooth for
sponsoring the podcast we love these
okay let's talk about Lucy baby oh Lucy
goosey shout out to him the nicotine
pounce that's changing the goddamn game
I don't use that crap that I used to use
now I'm a Lucy man yeah delicious
flavors it's absolutely fantastic do
yourself a favor get Lucy they got
whatever you need they got espresso
Berry mango whatever you want they got
available in different strengths you're
able to choose the amount of nicotine
that you want baby I don't like it too
strong you don't like it it's just
something to take the edge off Lucy's
here to help man and like I said visit
lucy.com
and use promo code garbage and get 20
off your first order shipping is always
free that's Lucy
l-u-c-y dot c o promo code garbage to
receive 20 off and always free shipping
Lucy products are only
for adults of legal age in every order
is age verified warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical
back to the freed list
I've never really I've never really
talked this much about I mean like on
come town we just say that my dad was a
rollerblading
which I don't want to take away from no
problem this is like I don't know this
feels this feels like like Inside the
Actor's Studio or something I feel like
I'm unbearing
uh what was a family vacation like
growing up we just go to our
grandparents house in in San Diego we
would just go to our grandparents house
really yes it was they had a pool I
guess was your mom from South Africa too
but both my parents were in Cape Town
yeah how did so one set of grandparents
your dad's grandparents stayed and my
dad's mom stayed his parents were
divorced but everyone else everyone came
to the states everyone split everyone
came in the states yes Southern
California so you had grandparents did
you have extended family in Southern
California as well yeah because like San
Diego yeah okay yeah we had my parents
were the first to come over and then
everyone basically followed really yeah
yeah nice they like I mean it's like
Southern California is kind of like Cape
Town it's like
it's this is is that true this is an
apartheid
no I mean it's just there's the beach
you know sure you can cut that that's
bored why'd I say that you know it's
fantastic the weather the weather is
very comparable they like Sydney and L.A
um yeah so I don't know so yeah but if
Growing Up in Vegas was weird I mean I
remember when there were kids I we used
to do weed and stuff and then I remember
kids you started doing meth that's a big
deal and I was like waitress I remember
we were just no like like the white
trash girls in high school like senior
Year we're doing math and I was like
we're just kids
we're just kids yeah I mean it's just
like Middle America it was pretty boring
sure and I remember also that there's
like girls like senior year you could
start dancing you could start uh
stripping at 18. so they'd be in our
class but also strippers and I'd be like
wow but whoa are you still waiting on
the pubes to come there this is weird
come on I didn't even think of that
that's crazy I remember there was that
one girl that started dancing and then a
bunch of kids in my class went to go see
your dance of course in retrospect
that's
it was really [__] up [__] up just a
bunch of guys be like oh man it's kind
of a weird place to grow up I can
imagine
um but I kind of like it now I kind of
like being from like a weird place does
your dad still live there my dad still
lives there yeah yeah just the same
house you grew up in same house he's got
a move but same house okay I told him
the downsides he's our family home but
whatever what was uh was the grocery
store that you guys went to out there
just uh Albertsons just so you know
respectable man yeah all right do you
have Albertsons out here wow
me oh yeah it's like that's like the
East Coast version Vaughn's and
Albertsons is where we go and Smith's
yeah just the regular ones
okay Deli counter what uh what kind of
car were your parents whipping around in
my dad we had the we had I remember
during the Firestone Tire incident we
had a Ford Explorer we almost died
with the Firestone do you remember that
all the tires on Ford Explorers were
yeah yeah were exploding and everyone
had that car everyone everyone in
America had that car yeah I remember
being like a child like eight or seven
just like petrified that the car was
gonna explode yeah it was like yeah we
had one of those and then my mom had a
Honda okay I think yeah respectable it
was a pet situation what a pet no pets
no pets at all no they make a mess yeah
really my numbers are neat freaks yeah
huh yeah yeah okay they keep saying they
keep lying like they get us a pet like
oh if you do like good as if you're a
good boy you'll get one of them you
never know they were Liars he's lying
second [__] I got a pet though I got a
pet though as a Revenge as an adult
what'd you get cat a murder dog
really do you have it now yeah you do
you got a thunder on the street no [__]
yeah her name is Isis
no no it was a guy was giving her away
on the street yeah he was like I was was
breeding her at my grandma's house to to
give birth to fighting dogs but no
cheese now she's homeless so she was
like a sad she was like a teen [__] oh
who got knocked up and then she was like
my puppies were taken away from me he
took her off the street yeah I made it
made it I made a hoe into a house yeah
there you go but now she's like lives
with a Jewish guy so she's like thinks
she is in a comfortable place in life
because she pulled herself up by her
blue shirt driving around your Mercedes
passion judgment yeah yeah yeah she
thinks she's better than everyone else
but she just found a nice man a nice
Jewish guy Jewish boy to take care of
her whatever it does look pretty funny
for me to be walking around with like a
murder at weapon on like just just the
vicious oh hello boy just for me like
just me and just walking around Brooklyn
then you go out with you have like
spikes around her collar or something
like that I like that no but she got in
a terrible terrible fight whenever his
daughter terrible fight like um like
bloody gory fight and then like we
rather lived in like Clinton Hill in
Brooklyn so like no you notice all these
like white people like did make it stop
like I don't know like what what I would
make it stop and I was like I don't know
I've never had dogs I just got this dog
I just found it I don't know and then
like there was like a like a Bagger
Vance like a ghost appeared and he was
like you want to get them to stop
fighting you put a you put a your
fingers
and I did it and then she like oh
immediately no [__] which is great I
didn't know that there he disappeared
then he went back he went back to the
Antebellum South or whatever yeah you
want to get them boys don't get hurt
what did the other dog get hurt yeah she
[__] up
the other dog was bigger than her and
also a pitbull and also [__] with her
but she got she's very she was scared
and defensive and then and then she she
snapped did the other couple start beef
with you
I mean the no it's fine okay yeah I
guess it was I was like I'll pay for
your
your dog's funeral but
I think the other guy was fine
come by and do a song yeah I played a
song on acoustic I'll play a a Candle in
the Wind
uh yeah so um how about you as a kid any
injuries no it's too safe too too
careful have you ever broken any bones
it's my pinky toe really
just hitting it on the corner of the
coffee table got you just indoors yeah
tough guy I like it
I got my mail I got my heart broken
I wear it on my sleeve they put me on
the DL for uh broken heart
that's all right yeah zero [__] till
18. what else you got
any more brain Busters all right what
else you got ever been arrested as a kid
I got pulled over for marijuana my dad
had to pick me up
it was [__] that guy was like that
guy's a [__] that cop Vegas
he was a [__] highway patrolman out
of jurisdiction on the surface streets
and he actually didn't see the weed at
all that's law school he saw that I got
he saw that I got a [__] I had a
hookah I was going over my boy's house
to smoke hookah and uh he's like he's
like I know what that is that's a bong
nah but I was so high when I was right
so high and then
um yeah so then he saw it he was like I
know what that is and he made me do like
a field sobriety but I was just I wasn't
drunk so I was like passing everything
and then yeah and then my dad had to
pick me up and tell me that I don't know
that I
bet his immigration wasn't worth it
I got riding on the line here I ruined I
could have been working on the front
lines right now yeah yeah it's a dealing
with you all right first concert
um
I went with my parents when we lived in
South Africa when I was a little kid we
went to go see Paul Simon whoa that's
when he was doing wait that like Paul
Simon oh [__] yeah it was Lady Smith
black mambaza damn I was a little kid
I've seen footage of that guy I had a
piss the whole time I remember and they
were like shut up I remember I kept
getting it I would get in trouble
I'll get in trouble and then try to
argue my way out I was one of those kind
of [__] okay I was a little bastard
um but then my first concert like
I think I went to like uh like Ska
concert
like no name bands I saw this band The
Toasters in the Aquabats
I feel embarrassed I'm only embarrassed
to say this because of [__] Ian acts
like it's still good like good music
because he's like trapped in childhood
he told me when we got Ernie Hudson on
the show he's like do I have a proton
pack and I'd love to take a picture with
Ernie I was like Ian grow up what are
you looking a four-year-old
there's something that's keeping him
there man how sick of that [__] is
already Hudson do you think I asked him
I asked are you going to call her I
asked him on the show I was like what do
you you must be sick of nerds I was like
you're a cool guy you got these freaking
nerds coming up to you like your whole
life probably yeah and he's like they're
not they're nice people and I was like
no no they suck yeah
he said he went to dinner with some
couple and the the husband
converted a Cadillac into the
Ghostbuster mobile and his wife had to
go to the [__] grocery store and [__]
driving that [__] yeah
I was like that's fun I like the
Ghostbusters but that's going pretty far
no there's just like that guy suffered a
horrific trauma yeah around the time
Ghostbusters came out and he is frozen
he is frozen yeah hey you got to
describe him my childhood
oh
all right let's see uh
uh were you the first time you had
Lobster
uh I don't know an adult probably okay
the lobster no yeah probably an adult do
you have milk with dinner growing up no
no that's for non-jee's yeah yeah I
remember I had Mormon friends in high
school and they had Kings Hawaiian rolls
at their house and I was like I was like
non-jews have the best food which I just
ate like a hundred Kings Hawaiians
they're so good
I had very similar to hola bread yeah it
is like a brioche yeah kind of thing
sweet very nice I agree there are a lot
of Mormons in Vegas I grew up with a lot
of boys yeah
um were you guys practicing uh Jewish or
just like culturally I mean I got a bar
mitzvah and stuff yeah I mean you're
pulling on the bar mitzvah uh
that [__] was stolen right your parents
took it my parents are like oh we're
putting this away for your future
all right I respect that
that's a that's a very Catholic move
right there I I'm I've never seen that
we have communion on our side we never
see a dime of that money oh my God the
Jewish kids usually clean up that's the
the ones whose parents do you remember
what you pulled in though I don't
remember at all 10 G's five G's I don't
remember it literally I do not remember
that like literally the checks just went
in the drawer damn Adam thanks you very
much
my friends like my friend David he his
parents were like in the sub Prime uh
Griff okay and when growing up in Vegas
he had his apartment he got a white
tuxedo with Tails and he had it at the
Four Seasons and his mom and dad got him
like motivational dancers to like like
sexy girls to dance with like us 13 year
old really I was taking the bar mitzvah
they got it they literally got us like
[__]
but it's just a 13 year old Jewish boys
some chicks on your school this is the
best night of my life no adult women 24
year old Jason we're down and out like
dancing for us no like hot they didn't
get a 1400 on the SATs I'll tell you
that one died so Diamond can I get you
some more punch
yeah yeah it was a weird place to grow
up okay
um hmm
how many suits do you own
um well I have one that I wear on the
show sure my dad's old suit okay from he
got it in the 80s I think
um and then I think
I have a blue one I have two other ones
okay can you tie a tie yeah for sure I
did speech and debate in high school so
I had to learn how to do it look at you
yeah I didn't learn until
[Laughter]
uh what was the job situation growing up
did you have any jobs pizza place
anything like that I I no I worked in uh
I like would work at like summer camp I
worked at summer camp like for little
kids when I was like uh between in the
Summers but I would go to Jewish summer
camp it's huge yeah because I wasn't
getting [__] in regular high school so
I'd go there start closing deals and
then girls would girls would Jamie oh
really yeah were you getting laid at
summer camp yeah it's a completely
different hierarchy no kidding you can't
imagine how
free you feel to play basketball
just like so much heart just like my
entire soul you're coming down the court
call now playing she was like yeah just
like confidence swish swish swish
out of general population it's
incredible basket was four feet it was
incredible
everyone's yamming the passion on
display all right I respect that tears
in my eyes absolute Master Class Jordan
flesh
Campbell's talking about rocket money
rocket money let's talk about getting
jammed up with a bunch of subscriptions
that you don't even [__] know about
and they're still coming at you taking
money out of your checking account you
could be using for all different kinds
of things rocket money's about to put
the clamp on that and as you know rock
of money formerly known as true bill
they go to check your subscriptions you
can 86 them right there it's a good time
yeah it's all in one place you can
cancel what you don't need to get rid of
uh the cat snack box you signed up for
eight months ago you the ramen of the
month subscription uh whatever you got
you might keep that one
uh you save yourself a ton of cash uh I
did I found out I was I was subscribed
to some movie thing that I signed up for
once about 18 months ago and they've
been [__] wetting their beat the
whole time save Tebow in a couple of
bucks too I know uh to end a
subscription just press cancel rocket
money takes care of arrest no need to
log in sign in Boop you get rid of
useless subscriptions with rocket money
now go to rocketmoney.com garbage
serious City could save you hundreds of
dollars a year and who don't need a
couple of bucks in their pockets day and
age that's rocketmoney.com garbage
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now rocketmoney.com
any time shares in the family
uh I don't know
what is a timeshare
oh yeah you're like you get a house
twice a twice a year I think my
grandparents had one at some point they
were big back in the 80s and 90s they're
still kind of big it was like a scam
right kind it's not not a scam you go
and then they say oh we'll give you like
a free you go they go yeah you go uh hey
come you just got a free weekend you
just have to listen to this three hour
pitch yeah yeah and then you go and then
it's like hey for 800 bucks
a year or whatever you get to use this
place twice so twice a year I'll say
this there's a lot of lawyers now that
advertise if you're jammed up in a
timeshare call me out yeah yeah so it
was predatory for yeah it was like put
it on a credit card yeah like that kind
of yeah yeah what's the Mayo situation
Hellman's Miracle Whip
we're at Costco everything you're a
Costco family Vegas sure makes sense uh
anyone in your family still have an AOL
email address no no fast let's go no
mine no no okay yeah yeah okay ever have
quail eggs
I've had them yeah yeah I've had them my
girlfriend my girlfriend is uh she cooks
good she cooks like she's like Gourmet
really she does really nice stuff
respectable Gourmet she's hot
uh you got you ever buy any products as
seen on TV I wanted I I for some reason
I wanted the Foreman grills so bad you
didn't have one
no we got one but I would watch it on TV
and I'd be like Dad you're a [__]
loser
idiot I was like it knocks out the fact
what's wrong with you I was like what is
wrong with you yeah like this is this
will be good for our family I don't know
why I was just together I wanted the
Foreman Grill so yeah it was a game
changer the showtime rotisserie never
hit like that for me really are you a
roto guy you like a rotisserie chicken I
just like that guy Ron Pope here
Ronco dude yeah we just did a whole
hitting me we just did a whole picture
on episode pretty much on his back
really dude sold [__] merch worth a
couple hundred million at romp appeal
what a guy yeah what a guy what a life
an American Dream he always had that
dumb broad with him but couldn't figure
anything out yeah there was always
someone juggling or whatever yeah yeah
those idiots those women
though these women uh have you ever gone
ghost hunting no okay come on have you
ever you don't believe in ghosts Jews no
nothing no I mean
you know
how you Bar Mitzvah they tell you Hey
listen there's no ghosts if you give me
12 I'm saying that there's no go no
ghosts I remember my parents told me
they was like by the way you know
because I'd watch everyone's so happy at
Christmas now I do Christmas with my
girlfriend's family really I hope what
did they say and I was like I was like
everyone looks so happy guys like this
sucks and they were like there's no
Santa no [__] I'm holding yourself I
just [__] tell all your [__]
friends gave you the real deal it was
diabolical Jesus whatever would you guys
go to the movies on Christmas Day
uh uh yeah I think so go to the movies
get a little Chinese I think we'd go to
the movies yeah all right in the movies
it's pretty classy I remember me and my
friend in high school we used to do the
deal where you get like a 11 A.M matinee
you see like four movies yeah that was
the best day yeah I kind of missed those
times I was always jealous of it not a
thing to do there's they're so nice you
just check the newspaper for the the
show times or we're gonna hit Crouching
Tiger then we're gonna hit you know
whatever sure Soul Plane there you go
[Laughter]
double header great movie uh do you
sneak snacks into the movie theater of
course yeah do you stop at snacks or
will you go crazy will you take food in
we take backpack tupperware's real
really yeah we're bad boys no I mean we
were just broke high school kids and
we'd like steal food from our moms well
you do that now though no come on do you
steal now will you take something from
the airport CVS Dwayne Reed sometimes at
the airport sometimes at the airport
just to feel yeah just to feel like
everybody does it man everyone why but
it's just free that's the rule right
I think man I think I worry about
getting jammed up by TSA testing it's
after TSA yeah I don't know who who also
you're afraid of a guy in TSA who's
jurisdiction I don't want to get jammed
you're out of jurisdiction
this is international waters it's the
international terminal goddammit we have
a hook on you
ever bought or sold anything on
Craigslist oh yeah for sure really would
you sell and or buy so many things
really that was a big
a big platform for I remember in college
we were in a dorm that they had a TV in
and the TV was half broken
and we sold the college's property I
bought a nicer TV wow that's all right
scam people are doing that now with the
monitors at like McDonald's and Taco
Bell are they they're selling them as
TVs and you get it to the house and it
just says it's like just as the menu
says the menu on it it's like it's like
hardwired like it's hardwired software
or whatever you have to hack it yeah so
you plug it in and it's just like the
[__] dollar man that is so cool I
wouldn't mind I love that show in here I
love that show that is a good restaurant
have you ever owned Skechers no come on
I'm trying to get laid
what are those that you're rocking right
now please yeah it's like uh those are
the Birkins dogs I got them for
Christmas for my girlfriend's mom there
you go I celebrate Christmas now by the
way you do a tree at the house we had
one we had a mini tree last year I I it
is it is so cool it is so good Christmas
is all right I've only had it for like
two three years it's just it is the best
thing ever yeah it's a good time I was
so jealous of it my whole life it's a
good time I remember like my first one I
was the night like 33 years old in bed
like I can't wait to wake up for
presents so [__] awesome see this fat
[__] speaking in I can't did you
get Hanukkah presents growing up I got a
little check on like day one I'd get
like a check for like 25 or something
and then I don't know
why don't you sign this over to me I'll
deposit it for you
don't feel bad I'm telling you I was
always jealous of my Jewish friends that
went out and went to the movies and had
Chinese food on I mean that's a nice day
it's a good time but I did that more in
like after I moved here to New York okay
yeah I've lived here for like eight
years but that it's that week in New
York is the best it's all [__]
awesome like for Christmas to New Year's
because the city is like half empty yeah
it's kind of shot down yeah but it has
like a really nice Vibe yeah everyone's
Vibe yeah yeah everyone hey how you
doing a little bit every bar is like
half full and you have the best night
decorations up the lights it's really a
really great week here they do shabby I
love it might be onto something
um ever break out the acoustic guitar at
a party no yes yes
you have a go-to song you would play
oh you stink really not at a party
explicitly but yeah but I kind of you've
shown off you've shown a girl yeah or
maybe like a couple girl
I mean not for a while but yeah I
um I really love to can you play well no
but I love I love to play and sing do
you have an acoustic guitar at your
house now yeah is it out like like on a
stand
uh uh I I have two guitars yeah I do
yeah yeah any of them on the wall no no
come on that's that's tacky
it's not new money all right
Eddie Van Halen I have it on the wall
what is this A Hard Rock Cafe
that's pretty good why would I have it
on the let me ask you this
if someone not extremely close to you
but an associate if one of us if we if
we're Capo reggiano what do you mean it
is
[Laughter]
not like a super tiger someone you may
or may not know okay let's say let's say
you and I run into each other at one of
the clubs and if I had a booger or bad
breath would you tell me probably yeah
good man we're guys we're guys we're
dudes were men I respect how guys act
right thank you yeah you got a [__]
bug on your face I like it I appreciate
it I like it your dick is hanging out of
your pants
come on I mean we're fellas no judgment
uh uh anyone in your family have a
standalone hot tub
just a hot tub really we do we had one
in our backyard no kidding in high
school yeah
was it always operational yeah right it
always falls to the latest and my dad
was like I'm gonna get it right this
year it's the same house so is it still
there it's still there it's just still
work no it's just still okay that's it I
remember when I got my first one of my
first girlfriends I try to have froggy
style sex in it
what's Rocky style SEC you know in the
pool just look at the top all right
guys
you guys want to find your Lily Pad you
guys have never had froggy style
yeah
I've never heard it you said a new
co-sign you know what am I a prude you
know I assume you're not having sex in
the hot tub
there's a lot of people out there
listening and I also it wasn't very good
at
sexy style dude dog [__] sex oh
terrified of sex I still am
I think I'm less scared but still bad I
never said I was good
will you
get a burger at a Mexican restaurant no
I'd recommend it they're always [__]
a home really I like a sit down at a
sit-down Mexican restaurant yes okay if
they have like a burger with like it's
always a home run I'm telling you right
what kind of Patty because I have a very
specific philosophy on Burgers
I don't like a restaurant Patty I don't
like a thick Patty really I don't
disagree with you I like uh are you a
Smash Burger guy I like a potato bun
minimal toppings American cheese potato
bun yeah like a flat Patty and uh maybe
white onion okay and minimum yeah I
don't like uh like a [__] aioli keep
it simple yeah yeah all right I think
that's a way better Burger
maybe you are Jewish I don't like I
don't like I just want a little raw
onion I just I mean I used to go to
[__] Applebee's and chilies with my
family growing up and now that was the
kind of burger you get you get the
restaurant Burger yeah the Pat the
[__] the bottom bun never the bottom
bun never ever
just it never works now well here's the
thing
Furious right now here's the thing if
you are say you're you have that
restaurant style burger at an Applebee's
or you can go to the neighborhood
whatever it is you know you take the
bite do you place it back down on the
bottom or do you invert it and sit it on
the top that's smart you go that's smart
I never even thought yeah the structural
Integrity of the bottom button do you
cut your burger in half you cut it in
half you do I do generally I copied my
dad dad cuts it in half my dad is he's a
real floppish Dandy
all right I'm gonna give you that hmm
try the Mexican burger Tony it's
phenomenal I'll try it I'll try it how
how I love a tableside guacamole
that is a real pleasure in life when
they hook it up seeing a guy make you a
guacamole you feel like a real Prince
oh my God you're like oh my God I'm the
Queen of England right now or salsa I
ended up saying thank you 12. I say
thank you every time thank you
no I'm always like so I act surprised
I'm always like what I would hate to do
that you got to be on your game all the
time but it really is a nice feeling
real it is you have a guy do it dude you
feel really fast yeah that and the
Caesar salad when they did that I feel
like a captain of industry yeah I like
the Caesar salad at the table clean
living how many emails would you say you
get a week
oh like like like from like uh me being
on a not um unsubscribing from things
yes
I have like 5 000 really I'm a mess my
email's a mess right now but it's but
it's all because I just don't
unsubscribe like I just like yeah the
[__] New York Times Like won't leave
me you know alone they got a lot of
balls too when you go to look at
something and they say you gotta sign up
for that give me a [__] break yeah
let me take a peek at the article how
many email addresses do you have
I try to keep it to one okay I try to
keep it that's respectable then I don't
like yeah I don't like merging different
email addresses I'm very sloppy I'm very
sloppy guy as an adult do you say
goodbye to places like a few places like
say you and your girlfriend
what do you mean say you and your girl
are at like an Airbnb or a hotel when
you leave do you say goodbye Hotel thank
you no no wait what is that
I could buy a hotel
it's like Goodnight Moon
there's not gonna be another guy in
there
it's a nice thing to do it's a nice
thing to do all right I'll give you a
classy on that one though
but I love it that is so sweet thank you
it's really nice to keep the building
I'm sure the architect loves it will you
talk to strangers at a hotel bar will
you strike up a convo no I don't think
so I do I
I guess maybe I talk to strangers more
than most people but I've kind of just
[__] with people really like but not
like in a mean way like I'll just make
up an insane lie huh yeah I'll be like
you know I'm [__] coming into
Pittsburgh for a volleyball tournament
they're like oh they got a good squad
this year got a great team though yeah
all right for no reason yeah I don't
know I used to do that way more when I
was younger yeah well you send people
venmo requests no good man no tacky you
open your eyes underwater
uh yeah
okay you take the customer receipt no
I'm good man no have you ever saved a
Crown Royal bag
okay are you flying up front mostly are
you you go you're going coach you do
coach yeah take your shoes off on the
plane yes you do yeah you bring food on
the plane no good man put your seat back
I mean sometimes I'll bring like uh like
a snack from Hudson that's okay dry
snack a package not like a tuna sandwich
feedback if the guy see back if the guy
in front of me
now do you just if you put the seat back
do you just drop it back or do you give
a peek behind you see what's going on
back there ah you can't give a peek
behind you and then they own your swords
wow that's very true you can't give them
that power okay if the guy in front of
you is doing it you can do it and then
they they have to shut the [__] up but
you're not gonna look at them and be
like sorry can I rape you with my seat
right now you can't like come on
all right uh have you ever owned cargo
sweatpants no have you ever had a hoodie
with the uh hole for the thumb or the
sleeve for the thumb uh I think so yeah
yeah ever burned a Jersey
burned a jersey with like a blunt or
something no no like a bit of Rage if
your team lost it
that is so funny that is so funny
do you wear shoes to the beach no no no
what's the credit card situation you got
an Amex I have a
a Chase Sapphire that's up there that's
pretty but I'm very I'm not very good at
these things I'm not good at money I'm
like you know like Jews are oftentimes
categorized as money or book
and I'm both illiterate and not good at
money do you read it all
this course page
I like Mike Lupica I like the [__]
the box scores baby yeah uh no yeah I
mean I've been listening to books okay
enough what are you listening to right
now
um I'm listening to the power broker
right now I'm TR but I'm not gonna
finish it I've tried to start this
episode 70 75 times
it's this book uh this guy Robert Caro
he wrote this book about
um he's like a famous historian he wrote
about this guy Robert Moses who's like
the guy who planned out New York City of
course Robert Moses he was the city
planner under mayor LaGuardia yeah yeah
yeah and he kind of like the way New
York I mean he like he built a highway
through the South Bronx and like yeah
yeah yeah put them in uh like poverty
for sure yeah I do know this book yeah
yeah built Long Island so everyone's
supposed to read this book or lie that
they have read this book and I've like
tried to start it I think maybe 10 times
do now I'm like if I listen to it and
it's it's like a hundred and something
hours it's gonna I'm not gonna finish if
you have general knowledge of a book
that you haven't read and someone says
hey yeah Adam have you read this do you
say yes yeah of course good man yeah
yeah the movie come on I lie about it
I've read about two books and I [__]
tell everybody well read I'm socialist
yeah I remember when scary movie came
out
in uh read the book no no no it looks
way better I remember like kids in my
class were telling like oh and then that
part is scary movie and then they say
the funny thing that happened I would
remember anything yeah memorize that
from from like uh sure over here not
seeing the movie and then just repeating
that to other people oh that's that's
really patheticle
it's very like sixth seventh grade like
very just trying to not get knocked up
yeah not be a freak sure just wanting to
be cool and have seen scary movie that's
all right any student debt yeah still
really yeah okay but I'm but I'm
chilling I feel like uh yeah I just keep
it because I think it's good for your
credit if you make regular payments yeah
there's something going on yeah I think
I don't [__] know credit I think
that's what someone's told me do you
know
I haven't looked I think it's all right
okay I don't know I don't have any
assets in my life I don't have any
equity in anything your rent now I rent
your rent what's a vacation look like
now were you in the were you in the
young lady yeah we went to my Grandmom's
house we went to my grandma's house we
literally did I took her to uh to South
Africa you did yeah right I took her
back to wakanda
yeah it's like we're back to wakanda
I was like these are my people totally
you were a prince yeah yeah we were King
we were Kings we was Kings yeah uh no
yeah so I took yeah we went back to
South Africa and then I'd never been to
Continental Europe before so we went to
France and Spain very nice very nice
it's very nice over there great [__]
awesome it's a big fan it's really even
though it's just it's very very nice
it's just the way they do it have you
been up here went for the first I've
never been out of the country before me
and me and the lady went last year uh
Christmas time and it was nice it's just
like it's really we like to [__] on them
because the whole 911 thing man they do
a pretty good job I still order freedom
fries
they do a real good job the food is good
the food is crazy Paris is Magic this is
what we're talking about on are you
garbage
and also he did take out a loan to go so
it does I took out a loan to go to
Hawaii oh whatever Paris
you know Tommy popes Paris story no he
was gonna like leave America for the
first time oh yeah on 9 11. so we got a
flight alone to Paris and then 9 11.
yeah I do know that I do know that shout
out it probably hasn't left since that
is so silly that is just so silly I'm
gonna go to Paris alone
do you know the acronym BOGO
b-o-g-o no what is it buy one get one oh
really you don't know that that seems
really that's huge that seems like that
seems like Eastern Seaboard okay even
the way you said BOGO it's just I'm a
Philly it just sounds like food Maryland
no you know water yeah water dude you
know like
yeah all right all right have you ever
ordered the Lumberjack special yeah for
sure your Lumberjack guy yeah as a boy
as a boy
what's your ultimate breakfast oh okay
all right whoa oh okay
I don't want to blow this up because
well I've talked about it before in
public lay it on us I just have a
concept
I think it's gonna revolutionize
breakfast I'm listening right okay all
right
this is gonna stink by the way everyone
hates it everyone hates it I'm in okay
so you have to make a choice
if you want a bagel you got to make a
choice between a Savory egg bacon
situation or a salty lox cream cheese
situation sure right yeah so my idea is
a 50 50. okay open face half lox Bagel
Capers onions okay tomato I'm with you
the other half soft scramble eggs and
bacon that's [__] not crazy I don't
hate this in a similar world my wife
does uh bacon egg and cheese with cream
cheese on it that's well that's really
good I've had that before yeah that's
really good gives you a little bit of
both that's a that's a nice plate you
know what I'm saying like that's all you
should be able to get both right and if
you're alone in life sure you don't have
nobody to share it with you don't have a
beautiful sexy girl you should be able
to get a 50 50. that's pretty good if
you had it if you had some kind of
special I'm going to start at Adam's 50
50 uh that's not bad man if you had like
six this is the most supportive anyone's
ever been of my idea
okay let's say you had six options all
right you have six options of Half Baked
so you can pair it up with
that's all right yes one could be a
Benedict
sure one could be sweet cinnamon raisin
you could yeah different combinations of
a different half a bagel yeah that's not
bad I mean essentially you could just
make them ahead of time and just have
like a bacon egg and cheese like if if
there was enough demand if you had and
you could just peace no made the order
made to order yeah that's crazy this is
what we're doing we get the boys we get
the boys in the kitchen we we get them
how are you gonna [__] grinding how
are you gonna what
as long as you're gonna make a sandwich
in a kitchen as long as you as long as
you do it we can't figure that out as
long as you do it businessmen if you
have an even number of options it's all
gonna work out and of course leftover
half Bagels that's what I'm saying
there's going to be left over chop them
up making croutons we'll run it as a
special hey relax there [__] Bagels
on the brain Jesus that's a name right
there Bagels on the brand Bagels on the
brain yeah
I'm out I'm out I'm out
you're out you'll be getting high on
your own supplies do you know from you
dog it's a no for me dog we need 30
grand for the initial investment yeah
um
you're missing out yeah yeah my my
family speaking of garbage I just found
out
uh from my uncle about my mom's mom I
always thought she was this Posh lady
she always
she'd like talk like that she's the one
in San Diego she's the one no she like
uh she you know she she ended up she
died in Vegas okay she moved to Vegas
um she uh he he said the funniest thing
to me like like poverty mindset he was
like no she was like um
she had 12 brothers and sisters they
were all born in different cities
because their family was were such trash
they kept getting kicked out of every
city in in South Africa like you know
like her parents came from the old
country gotcha she yeah and um they were
so poor
you guys are gonna do this
they were so poor that they would throw
their garbage uh out of their window
onto the street to brag to their
neighbors that they had food Jesus
that's an apple core don't you forget it
we have apples talk about flexing I like
it yeah it is they were horse thieves
apparently and I just knew this lady is
like oh my word yeah she used to like
talk like that there's still coming back
if you have literally like gypsies yeah
they're peasants that's all right shout
out to a horse I mean I'm go I I have
enough to render a decision here I just
got two more specifically based on horse
thieves in your bloodline I don't know
that's all Jews we're like we just have
the greatest comeback story in the 20th
century we were like getting murdered by
Cossacks and then the Holocaust happened
now we're now we're controlling the the
weather yeah
uh I got two more Bendy straw regular
straw what would you prefer
regular straw this is my most
conservative position politically okay I
straw technology is just the most
efficient way to drink okay you get the
most water
I'm [__] I I don't get these [__]
liberals trying to take our [__]
straws away I don't give a [__] about
the Turtles okay
I I I'm it made me Furious the paper
thing drove me nuts they stink it drove
me [__] nuts and yeah I'm glad the
straws are back it seems like people
have [__] yeah we were turning a line
down like we won that it seems like we
won that you know it feels like turtles
don't get me wrong but what the [__]
Jesus Christ
um all right so that that was one and
the other one two more actually yeah
have you ever had a Negroni
yeah for sure on a regular basis
I don't really like I mean like when
I've never had an alcohol and been like
ah yeah me either you know like I like
I've gotten plenty drunk in my day but
I've never been like this is you know
like my girlfriend's like this wine is
incredible and I've been like I don't
know yeah it's a Wine's lost it's an
alcohol that's pretty trashy I like it
last question how often do you wash your
hair uh uh like two times a week it just
looks worse after I wash it yeah I agree
and now I have to be beautiful for the
camera of course now I'm a talk got a
big show Big Talk Show [__] major
talk show now I'm uh you know a Titan of
the industry of course of course you
throw your trash out so everybody knows
yeah that's a half a bagel yeah [__] I
have food what do you think Kip I mean I
was gonna give him the coin flat he was
right down the middle I it's tough I
mean the fact that his parents still
have a [__] Standalone hot tub that
doesn't work tough look tough look and
then the fact he comes from horse
thieves tough luck I got Emily I'll go
60 40 trash on on a guy here yeah you're
trash kid yeah thank you
hey
by the way I lied about everything my my
grandfather is CEO of the Iraq War
I do have a feeling that you lied about
everything my family I kind of respect
my family invented opioids
my last name's Purdue suckers
Friedland is the stage name my real name
is Spielberg
do you see it I have not I turned to my
girlfriend and I said this is my
licorice pizza really yeah yeah I hate
it it's one for the boys it's one for
the for the these okay for us I was just
seeing I just haven't seen it I loved it
I saw everything everywhere all at once
I didn't see it I that I heard it was
doo-doo I loved it it was right I'll
tell you what I did I made the [__]
big mistake of watching the whale uh
Sunday night autobiography what are we
talking bro
no bueno yeah yeah I heard it was a dog
[__] but but Brandon but Brendan he's
brilliant in it he's great buddy we love
you man thank you so much for coming in
really fun uh you got the Adam Friedland
show anything else
on the on the show I don't know when
does this come out uh uh next week I'm
in Salt Lake next week the following
week I'm in Salt Lake City at Wise Guys
there you go the the Italian themed
Comedy Club Salt Lake City shout out to
Wise Guys Wise Guys good stuff
um and gang make sure you check out the
Adam Friedman show on patreon
patreon.com
t-a-f-s yeah we got a lot of really big
bookings coming up that we're really
excited I'm not [__] you it's wild
it's really becoming a real show and
it's it's really it it's just I don't
understand like people thought that we
were like doing uh we decided Nick and I
kind of made a conscious decision not to
do like a ironic talk show like
uh like Eric uh Andre I was gonna say
Eric Adams like Eric Andre but we want
to like ironically make it we won like
the two guys from the dumbest podcast of
all time to accidentally make a real
talk show that's awesome well you're
right there it seems looks fantastic so
I think it's I think it's coming
together it's been uh I saw this place
and I was like God [__] damn it these
guys put this together in 17 days we're
a [__] like we've Nick and I have
like literally threatened to kill each
other oh well we did that a lot nine
months yeah it was all Moonlight and
canoes what do you mean look at this
this is this is beautiful all those
pictures are covered up holes congrats
to you guys thank you thank you buddy
I'm really I love it here thank you man
congrats to you as well we're neighbors
we're we're just we're like uh
he told us about a lunch spot yo yo yeah
don't give it away no no we're not gonna
tell these yeah
between us the lines will be out there
what do you got for him uh guys we're
all over the road shows are selling out
we're adding second shows get your
tickets uh while they last we appreciate
it thanks come see us we love you very
much Adam Freeland one more time Adam we
love you buddy thank you boys and we'll
see you guys next week